[Müzik]
Deniz Üstü
Köpürür Hey Canım hayatına şöyle girsem
ne yaparsın bak al ya evet AB esinin
Gülleri Hadi Selamünaleyküm yavru
kurtlarım benim geldik şimdi neye tarihe
yardımcı bilim dallarına Arkan yaslan
list to mu çok veri K Hele bu kamerad
gelel bizim olan Gel bakalım şimdi tarih
dersi abim o kadar yoğun o kadar bütün
Dünyanın derdi o dünyayı Taşıyan
adamları ya Atlas onun gibi bütün bu
sınavların yükü kimde tarihçilerin
üstünde hamdolsun bizim derdimiz bitmez
bizim işimiz bitmez bizim konumuz bitmez
tamam mı anlat anlat anlat Bak daha
hiçbir şey yoktu tarih dersi vardı O
kadar yani hani tamam O yüzden bana
yardımcı bir sürü ne vardır bilim dalı
vardır arkana yaslan ve devam et Mesela
ama hani burada yazmadıkları var mesela
mesela matematiği fiziği kimya hepsi
bize yardımcıdır tek tek bahs vereceğim
onlardan şimdi yardımcı dallarından en
bilinecek en önemlisi hangisidir
arkeolojiden olmadığı dönemlerde o
bölgenin aydınlatılması işte adam
kazıyor kazıyor bir tane ıbr buluyor
çanak buluyor bir şey buluyor bak Bu ne
ıbr Tamam mı ha bu
ıbrıcak falan diyor değil mi İşte o
bölgenin işte aman an sen işte ya A o
coğrafyanın o bölgenin yaşam şartları
alakalı bize ne verir Bilgi verir
özellikle yazının olmadığı dönemin
aydınlatılmasında arkeoloji benim
Olmazsa olmazım dır Bir Biraz sonra soru
tiplerini de vereceğim coğrafya Hah
olmazsa olmazın bir de ne var benim
coğrafya var Bak benim coğrafyacım da
Önay cephe abiniz Tamam hemen alın onu
da takibe o coğrafyacılar bak yer bilimi
olayın geçtiği yer benim için önemli mi
o şartlar benim için önemli mi al
coğrafya bana bunu verir Dağı Ovası
bilmem nesi ıvır zıvır her şeyini bize
anlatır beraberinde kronoloji takvim
bilgisidir takvim yani kronoloji
sıralama ile alakalıdır olayların neden
sonuç ilişkisinde hangisi önce hangisi
sonra değil mi hangisinin etkisi
hangisini hangisinin tepkisi hangisini
buna bana hangisi verir kronoloji bilimi
verir beraberinde paleografya yazı
bilimidir
Tamam yazı Abim şimdi Dünya üzerinde
onlarca ne vardı Yüzlerce yazı vardı
bunların bir kısmısı unutuldu bir
kısmısı bilmem ne oldu E şimdi adam
mesela gazlı gazlı gazlı gazlı bir tane
Kil tablet buldu bir şey buldu mesela
tamam mı Göktürkçe Yazıyor E var mı
Göktürkçe bilen işte paragraflar biliyor
işte Onların işi bu peki paleografya
yazı bilimi neyle başladı Ahanda
sümerlerin yazıyı icadıyla Ahanda
paleografi başladı a bir cepte
beraberinde nümizmatik bankamatik peder
matik kredimatik değil mi Bitcoin matik
Aha nümizmatik ne bilimidir para
bilimidir Bu da kendi içinde ayrılıyor
Tamam meskukat bilmem ne falan diye
kağıt para ayrı metal para ayrı falan
falan diye ama para bilimi olarak bilin
Tamam beraberinde Etnografya kültür
bilimidir Bak her Devletin her ırkın
kendine has bir kültürü var mı var değil
mi Sadece biz Türklerin düğünlerinde
Tamam genelin arabas işte havlu bağlanır
kony yapılır değil mi halay at işte Ateş
edilir çocukl işi o vurulur aşağı düşer
damadın sırtına vurulur falan Bu kime
Has bizim kültürümüz Has herkesin
folklorü giyimi kuşa mı bilmem neyi
kendine has mı al Etnografya bunlarla
ilgilenir beraberinde ama Etnografya ile
neyle karıştırmayın epigrafya ile
karıştırmayın Kitab bilimiyle
karıştırmayın genelde bu ikisi
karıştırılır heraldik Aa bunu ÖSYM sordu
T öğretmenlerine de sordu alan sınavında
AYT ik kısım işte üniversite sınavında
da sordu herhald Arma bilimidir her
devletin kendine has bir arması var mı
Mesela Osmanlı Devleti'nin değil mi o
aklınıza geliyor bakayım müziklerde var
mı Aha bu tarafında var a Aha O işte
Arma bilimi mesela İngiltere Premier
Lig'de Aslan böyle topa basıyor bilmem
ne falan di hele şe verin bakalım bir
tane Osmanlı devlet armasını a a herhald
ki işte bunu inceliyor Bunlar ne
anlatıyor ne yapıyor onlardan bahsediyor
Tamam ağır bilgidir ve ben nerede bir
şey kıyıya köşeye yazdıysam Vallahi
ÖSYM'de onu sormu olmuştur haberin olsun
tamam beraberinde geldim ortaya ne var
diplomatika veyahut da siyaset bilimi
değil mi antlaşmalar antlaşmalar bunları
inceler a Dünya üzerinde bilen ilk
antlaşmada hangisiydi hititlerle
Mısırlıların yaptığı Kadeş
antlaşmasıyla sonra bakıldığında tamam
mı Kadeş anlaşmasından daha önce de
anlaşmalar varmış Bak al yeni arkeolojik
kazılarla bilgiler değişebiliyor muymuş
Evet değişebiliyor muu o yüzden öyle bıt
bıt bıt bıt bıt ezberleyeceğim diye
uğraşma Bunlar sürekli değişiyor Hele ki
tarih şey de şimdi ym taşal Taş orası
falan mesela komple değişti gitti
anlaştık Çünkü bilmiyoruz abi çok eski
yeni işte arkeolojik kazılar mevcut
bilgileri değiştirebiliyor O yüzden
bizim tarihte Kesin bilgi yoktur bu
budur bu budur bu budur Biz demeyiz
anlaştık hep ucu açık yorumlarla
bırakırız ortaya Tamam filoloji fil
bilimi değil nedir dil bilimidir Dünya
üzerinde onlarca konuşulmuş dil vardı
unutuldu gitti ama dille yazıyı
karıştırma İkisi aynı şey değil anlaştık
bak ikisinin farklı olduğunu bil
beraberinde epigrafya Kitabe bilimidir
Ha şimdi bak burayı şöyle soruyor Tamam
mı Bu işte önceden de o şu bilimin adı
nedir bu bilimin adı nedir böyle geç bu
iş bitti Artık yeni nesil Yapay Zeka çet
işte çipiti Ne Ne Ne bisi tamam Orada
şöyle geliyor diyor ki
Ural Altay dağlarının güneydoğusunda
işte yapılan kazılar sonucunda ortaya
çıkan yeni tabletlerin okunmasında ve
kitabelerin ortaya çıkarılmasında şöyle
şöyle şöyle şunlardan yapılmıştır Tamam
Buna göre Yukarıdaki paragrafa göre
tarihe yardımcı bilim dallarından
hangileri kullanılmıştır diye soruyor
bak yapılan kazıdı değil mi yapılan kazı
dedi Hemen Neyi aldım yapılan kazı dedi
bak aha arkeolojiyi bir aldım anladın e
yazı bilimi okumuşlar aldım E Kitabe
dedi epigrafya aldım tamam böyle
sorularla geliyor yani öyle bıt bıt bıt
ezberleme Tamam o kuru bilmeni istemiyor
artık yenin isi Sorular o bilgiyi
kullanabilmenin istiyor beraberinde
kimya ha kimyacıları da severiz bizim
kimyacı diyorum bum bum ne i diyor ya
aha kimyacılar ne Abim karbon 14 denilen
bir deneyi var Tamam karbon 14 denilen
Bu deney şu işe yarıyor
Tamam bulunan belgenin yaşını hesaplıyor
Hani nasıl ağacı kestiğinizde o
çentikleri sayıyorsun da ağacın yaşını
buluyorsun ya Şimdi bunlar da
mikroskopik ortamda Tamam öyle
bakıyorlarmış şeyle karbonların atom
yarılanma yılları oluyormuş nötron
Proton dönüyor bilmem ne falan falan ona
bakarak tan belgenin yaşını tahmin
ediyorlarmış ama Carbon 14 deneyinde 10
15.000 yıllık bir sapmanın olduğu da
biliniyor Ulan 10.000 yıl az bir şey di
Hadi 3 be yıl desen Eyvallah diyeceğim
10.000 yıl ne lan kurban oldum yani Bak
gördün mü o kadar eski ki insanlık
tarihi daha henüz bulamadık bilemedik
çözemedik Tamam dinler tarihle de normal
tarih işte çelişiyor E adam araştırmak
istiyor şey yapmak istiyor ama bilgi
belge olmayınca sınırlı sırıtıp
kalıyorsun beraberinde antropoloji en
sevdiklerinden birisi ırk bilimidir her
ırkın kendine has Tamam özellikleri
vardır mesela bunların işi daha çok
neyle antropologların işi tabi bunlar da
kendi içinde ayrılıyor siyasi antropolog
falan falan sosyal işte antropolog diye
Ama bunlar daha çok şimdi oldu bir kazı
yapıldı tamam mı Bir toplu mezar bulundu
Ee kime ait Bunlar nereden bilecekler
değil mi İşte her ırkın kendine has
özelliği var mesela sadece biz Türklerin
kafasının arkasında şurada Türklük eğeri
denilen bir kemik var bakma Sende de var
Tamam Hatta bu tıpa girmiştir Türklük
eğeri diye geçiyor Tamam beraberinde
beraberinde Eee işte atıyorum Ruslar
herkese şurada 4 kaburga var ruslarda
Soğuktan be kaburga var Anladın Japon
işte uzak doğudakiler göz çukurları
çekik bilmem ne kimin neresi uzun kimin
neresi kısa Bunu kim biliyor
antropologlar biliyor ırk bilimi Tamam
Genel kültür olsun beraberinde
sicilografya mühür bilimi ayrıntı bilgi
sevenlere Burası bir tık daha Yukarısı
mühür bilimi hani vardı ya o Spartakus
dizisinde B diye basıyor lardı ya Böyle
işte Ne o b bir şey B neydi lan o adam k
tuttum onu onun şeyi diye mühür
basılıyor Eskiden basıyorlar ineklerin
kulaklarına falan sahipleri belli olsun
diye bilin onomastik de Mesela yukarı
bandın Yukarısı Tamam yer isimleridir
yer isimleri Şimdi mesela Anadolu'da
bizden önce Anadolu'da kimler yaşıyordu
e Bizanslılar Romalılar yaşıyordu
buranın atları hep Yunanca idi Ee Mesela
bizim Isparta değil mi ısp parida bilmem
ne Barida imiş Tamam sonrasında
hamidoğulları kuruluyor hamidabad oluyor
Ondan sonrasında Isparta oluyor mesela
çok yerin adı mesela Antalya'nın adı
pamfilya idi sonradan Antalya oldu değil
mi İzmir'in adı simirna idi mesela çok
duyduğumuz yerler Kapadokya anladın a
Kapadokya ürküp Göreme o Civarın adıydı
Osmanlı'nın kurulduğu bölge mesela
bitinya değil mi Al bak yer isimleri
şimdi eskiye çalışıyorken Bakarsın bu
isimler birbirini tutmaz Bunlar yukarı
banttan tamam Ama burayı böyle
ezberleyeceğim diye uğraşmayın ha İlla
de ezber yapacağım diyorsan şöyle bir
şey yapabilirsin tamam mı Şöyle küçük
kağıtlar oluşturursun yi kartları hemen
şöyle şöyle kıvırdım büktüm tamam mı ört
benim Ben illa manyağım bunları
ezberleyeceğim ezberlemek istiyorum e
nasıl bir yol izleyeyim nasıl yapayım
diyorsan Eğer şöyle küçük bilgi kartları
tamam mı Yaz ona mastik arkasına yaz yer
at at kavanozun içine bir kavanoz
oluştur arada karıştır çek iki taraflı
çalışırsın özellikle mesela
ezberlemenin böyle ama çok ayrıntı
yazmayacaksın kısa öz net Tamam tık
hemen böyle bakıp
cevaplayabilir basit ama etkili bir
yöntem olduğunu görürsün tamam aha
buraları işte böyle paragraf verip
hangisi var Hangisi yok hangisi var
Hangisi yok öyle soruyor genel
itibariyle de sorduklarını söyleyeyim
sana tamam mı epigrafya Kitab ilimini
bil diplomatika Siyaset bilimini bil
Tamam mı şunlar ağır sınavlarda gelir
sicilografya onomastik heraldik falan
tamam etnografyası bil nümizmatiği bil
paleografi bil arkeolojiyi zaten
biliyorsun anlaştık bu tarz sorularla
gelir Ha bir de buraya yazmayı unuttuğum
bir tane daha var sosyoloji O da toplum
bilimidir Aha O da toplum
bilimi ha E hocam hani matematik Sana
yardım etmiyor mu ediyor nerede Şunların
hesabında Şunların çevirmelerinde falan
o da bize yardım ediyor Şimdi biz o Rumi
hicriye Hicri miladiye falan çevirme
işleri var 33'e çarpıyorsun 34'e
bölüyorsun 580 küsür ekliyorsun Ulan ben
bir sayıyı 33'e çarptım Hadi kazaya
Kudret bak some sözelci problems Tamam
34'e ben onu katiyyen bölemem Hadi
böldüm 584 ekleyemem ben tamam Allah
razı olsun bamer de bize orada yardımcı
oluyor some sözel problems Peki şimdi
yardımcı bilim dalları Bunlar Malum
bizim işimiz çok yardım eden çok bize
Peki takvim Peki takvim What does
Calendar mean ne demek lan takvim takvim
ne takvim şudur abci takvim zamanı
zamanı gün
ay yıl olarak bölen alete araca ne
diyormuş takvim diyormuş tamam mı Bak
netlik kazandıracak bize şimdi takvimler
Deen iki tane takvimimiz var biri Güneş
yılı esaslı biri Ay yılı esaslı bunları
ilk Ç anlatırken nasıl bulduklarını
orada anlatı vereceğim bu Güneş yılı
esaslı takvimi Mısırlılar buldu Tamam
Nasıl buldular işte Nil nehrini taşma
zamanını hesaplıyoruz ediyoruz kılıyoruz
falan derken gökyüzüne bakıyor ama
burada bileceğin genel bir şey var Eğer
bir adam takvim yaptıysa neyde takvim
nin bu takvimler neye bakarak yapılır
havaya suya kızlara neye Instagram'a mı
Hayır abiciğim gökyüzüne bakarak
yaparsın Eğer astronomi gelişmişse Tamam
orada takvim işleri de vardır bunların
bağlantılı olduğunu bilin Güneş il esası
takvimi Mısırlılar
buldu Romalılar aldı Tamam papan bilmem
ne zamanında ayar çakıldı günümüzdeki
Miladi takvim oldu peki beraberinde ay
yıl esaslı takvimi ise Sümerler buldu
Tamam onlar da zik kurat denilen
tapınaklarında gökyüzünde tanrıyı arıöz
derken herfler takvimi buldu onu da
Müslüman İslam dünyası aldı günümüzdeki
Hicri takvim oldu ama Miladi takvimle
Hicri takvim arasında ikisi arasında tam
11 günlük bir fark vardır Tamam tam 11
günlük bir fark vardır Hocam bu bu niye
böyle bu abiciğim buradaki mesele şu
Arkan yaslan ve dinle tamam şimdi Eee
bizim kullandığımız hakimlere
baktığınızda şurada Mesela biz en
başından beri neyle geliyorduk ayr esası
takvimlerle geliyorduk değil mi Sonra
Güneş res esası takvime geçildi ama işte
sıkıntılar ortaya çıkacak 11 günlük fark
var Bak her yıl ramazan bayramı kurban
bayramı 11 gün geriye geliyor değil mi 2
yılda 22 gün 3 yılda bir ay geri yatıyor
değil mi 30 küsur yılda da bir tam tur
dönüyor mu dönüyor Mesela şimdi ben
mesela küçükken Biz kışın oruç
tutuyorduk Mesela şimdi yazın
tutuyorsunuz değil mi E sen de mesela
yaşlılığına doğru mesela şeye doğru
gelecek kışa doğru gelecek mesela neler
oruçlar değil mi E şimdi sen genciken
abim orucunu falan tut Tamam ibadetin
bak genci keni makbuldür Tamam yarın bir
gün sen de anti ktin hastalıklar çıkar
edemezsin kefareti de ağır onun Sen
orucunu Tut bak Nereden nereye bağladık
Tamam aha bilin takvim meselesi de bu
arada 11 günlük fark varmış biri 365 gün
6 saat birisi de 354 gün anlaştık Bir de
artık o 6 saatler falan var hele
bunların hesaplamaları falan Allah'a
emanetti biz mesela üniversite fakültede
eyken Şunların çevirileriyle uğraşırdı
Biz abim yani hicir işte çevireceksin
33'e çarpıyorsun işte atıyorsun 1330
tarihini 33'e çarpıyorsun 34'e
bölüyorsun 5 lan bunu ben nasıl yapayım
kurban oldum Ya ben bunu yapaydır zaten
Tıp okurdum ben yani e kurban oldum Ah
sonradan işte Hesap makineleri şeyler
çıktı Allah razı olsun O Paskal denilen
adamdan Hesap makinesini o bulmuş Tamam
A bu peki geldim şimdi gel bu kameraya
gel bu yanına gel Aha Türklerin
kullandığı takvimler Biz Türkler
abiciğim önce bir Orta Asya'da Ken 12
hayvanlı takvimi kullandık Bu güneş yılı
esaslı bir
takvimdir teknik bir Baksanıza la bu yıl
bunu şimdi Çinliler kullanmaya devam
ediyor Biz islamiyet' geçince Hicri
takım geçtik unuttuk biz onu tamam mı
Ama şu an hala şey kullanıyor bunu
Çinliler kullanıyor bu takvimi Peki sana
objektif bir soru Tamam kim ki mi
etkiledi biz mi Çin'i etkiled yoksa Çin
mi bizi etkiledi tamamen objektif
tarafsız yansız nesnel bir tarihçi
olaraktan cevap veriyorum Tabii ki biz
Çin dedik Onlar ne bilecekler kısık
gözüyle bakıp da gözün nereden görecek
onlar Tamam biz biz öğrettik onlara
Bunun aksi olduğunu bana ispat edemen
Tamam lan Bir de öyleymiş Neyse boş ver
Tamam biz yaptık kardeşim ya Allah Allah
ya sahip çıkmazsan adamlar üstüne
konuyor işte tamam mı bir bakar mısınız
Bu yıl ne
yılıydı ya ejderha yılı mıydı 2025 miydi
ejderha yılı hangisiydi bir Baksanıza
teknik Bir söyl bakalım bana bu yıl ne
yılı Ç şeyde Çin takviminde
a süreniz doldu Hadi Bulamadın
mı ne
yılı Aslan yılı Aslan mı Yanlış baktın
değil Kaplan atma lan atıyordu aslan
kaplan saydırıyor yılan ejderha Vallahi
benim aklımda ejderha yılı diye kalmış
da bu yıl mı Seneye mi Neyse bilen
yorumları aşağıya yazı versin baştacısın
Tamam beraberinde İslamiyetin kabulüyle
beraber neye geçtik hicri takvime geçtik
bu takvim işte Ay yılı esaslı Tamam
sonra Türk İslam devletleri işte eee
büyük selçuklulardan sonra mesela şu
sorunu yaşadılar ülke içinde yaşayan
hristiyanlardan hocam baktık neymiş
ejderha ejderh mış değil mi Evet
Ulan Google'a Kardeş kurban oldum Siz
niye bana inanmıyorsunuz ya he niye
benim aklıma gelir ben biliyorum dur
kuvvet ihtimalle onları Tamam al şimdi
Neyse bu Büyük Selçuklu topraklarında
yaşayan gayrimüslimler E şimdi bunlarla
vergi alacaksın Ulan adamlar başka
takvim kullanıyor sen başka takvim
kullanıyorsun Şimdi adamlardan Bu yıl 1
Eylül'de aldın vergiyi Tamam seneye 11
gün önce geliyorsun 2 sene sonra 22 gün
önce geliyorsun 3 sene sonra bir ay önce
geliyorsun bu algı vergi işlerinde
sıkıntılar oluyor diye tamam büyük
Selçuklular Melikşah devrinde neye
geçtiler Ay yılı esaslı takvime geçti
kim geçti buna Büyük Selçuklu Ömer
Hayyam'a yaptırıldı Vezir nizamül
mülk'ün önderliğinde Tamam Celali
takvimine geçtik beraberinde benzer
sıkıntıyı Osmanlı'da yaşadı e tebaasının
içinde gayri Müslüman vergi alacak
sıkıntılar oluyor değil mi Aha
Osmanlı'da ı Mahmut'la beraber geçti
İşte bunlar neyle alakalıdır Bunlar
ekonomi işlerini düzenleme ile
alakalıdır beraberinde 2 Abdülhamit
zamanında mesela garbi Takvim Ana
şunları hep ay ay yazdık şunlar ay değil
hemen düzelt şunlar Güneş tek Ay yılı
esaslı
hangisi Hicri takvim olacak Aferin sana
iyi gördün Aferin sana Tamam sonra gel 2
Abdülhamid zamanında güneş yıl esaslı
bir takvime geçildi süreç devam etti 1
Ocak
1926'da bütün dünyayla beraber biz de
Miral takvime geçtik anlaştık bilin
Tamam şimdi buradan bir de MEB kitabında
sürekli giren çıkan şu hesaplamalar
vardı çeviriler vardı ve eski zamanlarda
2001 2002 2003 o tarihlerde vardı MEB
kitaplarında çıkardılar şu an artık
onların hepsini programlar yapıyor yani
hani tamam Eee şu Yüzyıl kavramını da
meing 2018'deki güncellemesinde çıkardı
da şimdiki kitaba dahil ettiler Yüzyıl
kavramını bilin Yüzyıl kavramı önemli
bir kavramdır ama ona geçmeden önce
şöyle bir soru tipi daha var
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi daha belirgindir
diye bir soru var şıklara Bak a yazı
milattan önce 3200 lde
bulundu bak B
Eee ne diyelim B'ye B atın bir şey tamam
Ateş bundan yaklaşık 15.000 yıl önce
kullanılmaya başlandı
belli mi onu da bilmiyoruz değil mi
arkasından C Mustafa Kemal 19 Mayıs
19'da 1919'da Perşembe günü Tamam saat
9.30'da Samsun'a çıktı şimdi burada neyi
arayacağım daha belirgindir sorularında
Eğer gün ay yıl varsa onu arayacağım
anlaştık ya da işte Ha Haçlı Seferleri
13 yüzyılda işte 11 yüzyılda gerçekleşti
İstanbul 1453'te fethedildi Mustafa
Kemal Atatürk Samsun'a 19 Mayıs 1919
günü Bandırma vapuruyla çıktı hangisi
daha belirgin gün ay yıl olan daha
belirgindir anlaştık soru tipidir ve
şimdi geldim Bir de neye şu Yüzyıl
kavramına şu tahtanın şurasını Bir
sileyim ortaya gel Babam Ortaya Gel
Şurayı da şöyle bir silelim Oo silginiz
çok güzelmiş yeni aldınız galiba aferin
size retro Yayıncılık şöyle Şurayı bir
silelim Tamam şurada bir de şu Yüzyıl
kavramını anlatalım burayı sayısalcılar
rahat yapıyor da bizim sözelciler Ben
falan bizim kafa biraz zor alıyor burayı
şimdi arkana yaslan ve dinle tamam
Yüzyıl kavramı şöyle bir şey yapacağız
şöyle bir sayı doğrusu çizeceğiz Tamam
şöyle şuraya doğru gitsin şurası şurası
s0 dediğimiz Milat olsun Tamam 0
dediğimiz Milat olsun günümüze doğru
geldikçe rakamsal değer olarak büyüyerek
gelir değil mi İşte 25 değil mi 50
arkasından 75 arkasından 100 sonra 200
300 kurban benimki niye eski onlar
sendikalı Ben de Harranlıyım de yılımızı
ne zaman şu an 2024'e geldik günümüze
yaklaştıkça rakamsal değer olarak
büyüyerek gelir milattan önceki rakamlar
ise günümüzden rakamsal değer olarak
uzaklaştıkça daha uzak daha eski bir
tarihi belli eder şurası 25 şurası 50
şurası 75 şurası 100 olacak şekilde 100
200 300 değil mi böyle devam eder Peki
niye böyle Çünkü şunu bilmiyoruz abi Şu
başlangıcı bilmiyoruz yok bilsek orayı
gideceğiz işte gidebildiğimiz kadar
eskiye gideceğiz anlaştık o yüzden şu
başlangıcı bilsek ha 0 1 diyeceksin
oradan başlayacaksın anlaştık Şimdi bir
de burada bileceğin şöyle bir şey de var
tamam mı şurası mesela 0 la 25 arası
değil mi 1 yüzyılın 1 çeyreği 2550 Arası
2 çeyrek şurası Ne diye geçiyor 1
yüzyılın 1 yarısı diye geçiyor
arkasından şu taraf 50 ile 75 arası aynı
basketbol maçı gibi vallahi var ya
şurası 3 çeyrek 751 arası da 4 çeyrek
şurası da Ne diye geçiyor ikinci yarı
diye geçiyor değil mi ve saymaya nereden
başlıyorsunuz sıfırdan haz İsa'nın
doğumuyla başlıyorsunuz değil mi Aha
milattan önce 3200 lde şuralarda bir
yerlerde yazı icat edildi ve Ne başladı
ilk çağ dediğiniz şey başladı devam etti
milattan sonra 375 Kavimler göçüyle
değil mi İşte şey Başladı ortaçağ
Başladı İstanbul'un Feth 1453'te Yeni
Çağ başladı bu böyle geldi tamam Şimdi
bir de burada bileceğiniz Olay şu
sorarken size tamam mı ÖSYM bazen şöyle
geliyor diyor ki
15 yüzyıl diyor Hadi buyur buradan yak
la 15 100 yıl hangi yıllar abem hangi
rakamı verirse versin 15 mi dedi bir
düşersin 1400' LD 1400' 1499 arasıdır
niye hocam Çünkü saymaya birden
başlamıyorsun maya nereden başlıyorsun
sıfırdan başlıyorsun aynı doğduğun yaş
gibi Çıktım ben kadrajdan B beni bir
alın bir bütün M bonuz yan alıyoruz ha
yan al burada kal Hah tamam aha bak
mantıklı şeyi değil mi B saymaya nereden
başlıyorsun sıfırdan başlıyorsun
anlaştık o yüzden Aynı şey gibi işte yaş
muhabbeti gibi işte Kaç yaşındasın kaçı
doldurdun e doğduğunda 5 yaşında
değilsin ki 3 aylık 5 aylık falan diye
geliyor mesela böyle bilin Bir tane
düşeceksiniz Mesela dedi ki 19 yüzyıl
dedi değil mi bir düşersiniz
kaçlarda desem ki bunu yazılılarda falan
öğretmenlerim sorar Mesela atıyorum
1800 32 tarihi Kaçıncı yüzyılın kaçıncı
çeyreğidir diye gelsem ne dersiniz
kaçıncı yüzyılın kaçıncı çeyreği
1800'ler kaçıncı yüzyıl
yüzyılın ilk yarısının
doğru mu ikin
çeyreğinde dir yorumu doğru mudur Evet
doğrudur anlaştık bak nokta atışı bilgi
bu milattan sonra için böyle milattan
öncesi için Burası milattan sonra sıdan
sonrası bu taraf ise
M milattan önce before Christ İsa'dan
öncesi diye geçiyor değil mi şimdi
burada ters mantık yürüteceğiz Niye
şimdi önce hangisi yaşandı milattan önce
mü milattan önce 25 mi önce Burası
yaşandı Milattan Önce 100 ile 75 arası 1
çeyrek 75 50 arası 2 çeyrek 502 arası 3
çeyrek 251 arası ise günümüze daha yakın
olduğu için 4 çeyrek olacak şurası 1ci
yarı Burası da ne olacak
2ci yarı olacaktır yani buradaki terse
çevirip öyle yapmanız lazım
zannetmiyorum Öyle bir soruyla da
gelsinler Buray ı bir kere ÖSYM şöyle
bir soruyla geldi görseli sözel verdi
Bizimkiler anlamadı soru dedi ki Milat
dedi sıfır haz İsa'nın doğumu kabul
edilir dedi tamam Ha Hayırlı uğurlu
olsun milattan sonraki tarihler rakamsal
değer olarak arttıkça
günümüze yakınlaşır milattan önceki
tarihler ise rakamsal değer olarak
arttıkça günümüzden daha uzak daha eski
bir tarihi e simgeler dediler Buna göre
hangisine ulaşılabilir dediler şıklara
bak milattan sonra milattan sonra iki
tarihin farkını bulmak için ne yaparsın
milattan sonra 100'le milattan sonra
400'ün farkını bulmak için ne yaparsın
çıkarırsın değil mi Doğru böyle bir
seçeneklerle geldi peki milattan önce
100'le 300'ün farkını bulmak için ne
yaparsın gene çıkarırsın değil mi peki
peki milatta önce 100'le milattan önce
100'le milattan sonra 100'ün farkını
bulmak için ne yaparsın çıkarırsan İşte
oraya Tüü dikersin 100'den 100'ü çıkar 0
kalıyor olmadı işte bu ikisinin farkını
bulmak için de toplama işlemi yapılır
niye 100 yıl burada yaşandı 100 yıl da
burada yaşandı 200 yıl var değil mi
böyle bir soruyla geldi sayısalcılar çıt
işaretledi geçti Niye sayı doğrusunu
çizerdin Tamam ben falan o soruyu
çözerken Ulan Bakı y La dedim bu ne
diyor bu dedim yani böyle matematiksel
ifadelerle geliyor işte seviyor bu tarz
işleri ÖSYM haberiniz olsun aklınıza
yattı mı he he mi Tamam al takvim
bilgisi Yüzyıl bilgisi Ne bileyim işte
şey bilgisi Bak a 224 yılındayız hangi
yüzyıldayız bir tane ekle
21 yüzyıldayız anlaştık 21 yüzyılın ilk
yarısındayım 25'ten sonrasında artık şey
değişecek an açtık Aha geldim şimdi Bir
de burada bu takvim bilgisi şey bilgisi
tarihin işte faydaları zararları falan
falan falanları bunlardan da bahsettik
Tamam şimdi Sırada ne var Şu tarih
öncesi devirler var yontuk taş cilalı
taş bilmem ne taş oralar komple değişti
Tamam gene ben size bildiğimiz kadarıyla
anlatı vereceğim dedim Bundan sonra ne
oldu yonma taşta ne olacak cidalı taşın
özelliği ne maden devrine kim geçti
yazıyı Nasıl buldular la hepsi ve daha
fazlası Az sonra Haydi görüşürüz bakalım
[Müzik]